i mean the story of my career is just
the story of a whole lot of
real good luck my guess is is that the
best is yet to come
and i have no idea what it is because
that's the way
my my life has really worked meeting
carol
to becoming an actor to all of the best
things in my life
have been accidents have just happened
to me
and i've had the good sense to recognize
it
it was an open call when i showed up at
the soundstage there were probably
maybe 50 actors there and francis
he picked four guys and he said here's
the deal
you're in a boat the engine is off
you're floating down the mekong river
and you're having an argument who the
playmate of the year should be
and they begin to have this argument
doing great improvisational work
yelling at each other and i'm sitting
there watching it and i guess
at a certain point i rolled my eyes kind
of like this
and francis stopped the improv he said i
saw that scott
these people are doing serious work i
don't need you making a comment on this
work
why did you do that and i said it wasn't
that the work was bad but these guys
are on a boat with the engine turned off
floating down the mekong river
you scream and yell like that you're
going to have a mortar round
in your laps in five seconds and francis
looked at me
and turned to his a.d and he said i want
him in my movie
i got to the philippines it was friday
almost everybody was going back to
manila
to have their weekend and i decided i'd
just stay
on location that friday evening the
worst typhoon to hit the philippines
since 1932 came in
typhoon everybody thought we were dead
for for two days we lost all contact
uh we were on an isthmus that was turned
into an island
we had to sort of organize the place
there was a woman who was
pregnant with twins since i delivered my
second daughter myself i was the only
person who had any idea of how to do
that so
finally two three days later francis
came back on a helicopter
all of our sets were destroyed we
obviously had to
rebuild things and start all over again
we went down to the edge of a stream
uh that they were that they were going
to shoot on which was now a
white water because of all the water and
francis the insurance adjuster i think
victorious dora the
the dp and three or four guys got on
this boat and they were gonna
go out onto the stream to take a look at
it
they tied a rope on the back of this
boat and
let the boat out onto the stream
thinking if the stream carries it down
downstream very quickly they could pull
it back
and i'm watching this from about 50
yards away i
was not that long out of the marine
corps always had a knife
and when i saw what was happening i just
realized the minute the tie gets that
boat it's going to snap it straight
downstream
and the rope is going to pull the back
down and the boat's going to sink
so the minute they let it go i started
running towards the rope
dove at it cut the rope didn't sink
later on that night francis said you
saved my life
and i said i don't know if i did or not
i just acted on instant
and francis said you've helped me out so
much
i can write you a better part than you
were cast just tell me what you want to
do and i'll write it right now and i
said i want to be in the end of the
movie
and he said what and i went yeah i'm
gonna be
in the part at the end of the movie with
marlon brando and dennis hawker
and francis said i'm scary scott but
there is no that's the only part of the
movie that's completely cast
there's nothing in it for you i mean you
could play captain colby the guy that
went up the river ahead of
martin but it's a tiny part
very few lines but if you want to do
that
i'm good to my word and i said i do
call me i realized at the time that
acting
is serving an apprenticeship you really
can't learn how to act
in school or from a book or and i was
going to be around
arguably the america's greatest actor
francis working with him
so that's how that happened
[Music]
carol's laughing right now i i got call
from my manager johnny planco another
one of my best friends who's no longer
with us
but at the time he said marvel
is really interested in your playing
this character
stick i didn't know any of those
characters at all
and he said it's the mentor to the
daredevil that will be played by charlie
cox and i went oh
and i got so angry because i thought
the mentor yeah i'm going to play some
old guys just behind the desk
and sends young actors out to do
all kinds of fun interesting stuff this
is going to be a pain in the butt and i
don't even think i want to do it and i
got real and i got
stupidly angry there's a hike south of
here
that's very steep and in in fewer i
ran up the side of this mountain it was
so steep and i was
you know so full of myself stupidly with
my big dumb ego
that i jammed my hip coming down got
home
and they had sent the script and i
started reading the script i went
whoa this this is a blind
assassin who's an expert with swords and
knives
and comes out of this incredible dark
crazy background and has adopted this
kid
i don't even i've never even played
blind how to
and all of a sudden i felt stupid
because i went from hating the idea of
the part to loving
the actuality of the park
nice catching up i remember when i met
the stunt coordinator he
said do you know anything about martial
arts and i went
yeah a little bit and he said what about
martial arts with
knives and swords and i said yeah a
little bit he said well how long have
you been doing this stuff and i said
kind of since i was 10 years old and i
remember he had
a couple of fake rubber they were long
knives i said well
we want to spar a little bit and he said
sure
so we started we were knocking over
racks of
dresses and and after about
probably two minutes he just stopped in
the middle of it you can do all this
stuff better than me
why i'm not gonna double you with any of
this and at the time i just met
a guy who has become my sifu dan
anderson
his dojo is broadway and canal and so
when i wasn't doing the tv show in
brooklyn
i was at anderson's just playing with
knives and swords and stuff like that
i was in europe and i got a package in
the mail
and it was from larry kasda he said here
i wrote this part for you
what do you think and i read silverado
and i yelled
yeah and threw the
script up in the air and danced around
the hotel room i was so
happy so larry wrote that wrote that
sucker for me
you men stay with your wagons and your
families
get rolling keep your eyes peeled wait a
minute
even if you do get the money how do we
know you'll come back
well if we don't you keep my brother
first thing
he said is there anyone here who can't
ride horses
and danny glover and i took one big step
forward
and everyone else didn't i always
consider it
to be unwise to pretend you can do
something you can
danny and i were given by the wranglers
horseback riding lessons
every day up until when we began
shooting
about four days before we began shooting
clara caston picked the horses he wanted
each one of us
characters to ride and for me it was a
huge quarter horse the size of a
clydesdale but a pure quarter horse
gray named ajax and he told the wrangler
freddie someone's got on that horse and
fred said no that's my own horse
stunt riders can't ride the ride that
horse he just turned five so he's very
young
and he's already two times world steer
roping champion
if you get near this horse with a pair
of spurs on he's going to kill you
and i said you know what
why don't you saddle the horse and let's
see
if the horse tries to kill me or not so
as i was walking
out towards this big horse i remember
animal trainer woman named barbara
woodhouse
saying that horses communicate with each
other by blowing into each other's noses
so i'm walking out
and i walk up to this big horse and he
kind of looks at me
and i said to begin with ajax i'm
supposed to tell you i'm the boss
guess what i'm not you're way bigger
than me
you're way stronger i don't know
anything about riding i'm talking to the
animal
i said so you're in charge you're the
boss and
he brought his nose right up to my face
so when he did i blew in his nose
and he blew back at me and hit me with a
wad of snot the size of a snowball like
right my face
i wiped it off and he just stood there
i put my foot in the stirrups got up on
on him set this out he didn't move
i went he starts walking
i'm thinking i don't even feel myself
motioning to the left he goes to the
left i do it to the right
he moves to the right i touch him with
my heels now this is
a world champion steer roper i touch him
with my heels
he goes from a walk to a straight out
hard gallop
but i'm comfortable on him and at one
point
we go to the left we go to the right
it's like being on a sports car at one
point i think i want them to stop
i drop my heels and say whoa
this horse is used to jerking steers on
their butt so he
does like that i go over his head
and land in the ground luckily i didn't
break anything but the minute i landed
on the ground
ajax trotted over to me put his big
muzzle on my face
and started rubbing me with his head he
fell in love with me
people see that movie now and they think
i'm an expert rider
i'm not i still really don't know how to
ride horses
it's just that this monster phenomenal
athlete
love me
[Music]
i had a part in a western called the
great northfield minnesota raid
directed by phil kaufman i had to go to
universal to
uh to meet the producers
and just get to know them and the
producers walked in
phil said this is scott glenn he's going
to be playing this part
and he said great great we just want to
meet you great so we'll see you on
location
i hop on my motorcycle i drive back to
venice where we're living the phone is
ringing i pick it up it's phil kaufman
he said i couldn't let an agent or
someone else tell you this guy
you're not going to be in my movie
you're half an inch too tall
and i remember saying i'll wear
moccasins i'll
drop my knees down a little bit a half
an
inch he said i'm sorry it's not going to
work
but the next time i have a film where i
have real control
i'm going to send you the script and you
get to pick your part
i get sent the right stuff i call phil
kaufman up and i said i know what i want
to play
and he thought i was going to say
chuck yeager or maybe john glenn and i
did not
i said i wanna i'm gonna do alan shepard
and there was a long pause
and he said alan shepard well that's
kind of a comedic part and i said yeah i
know
it's funny that's right that's what i
want to do i want to be the icy
commander
dear lord please don't let me [ __ ] up
i didn't quite copy that say again
please right
i said everything's a-okay and he said
i'm good to my words scott you want to
be alan shepard
you are alan shepard would you like to
meet him and i said absolutely not
i went home movies of him as far back in
his life
as possible i want everything i can see
recorded about him
but i don't want to meet the guy himself
because if you
play somebody and they know that their
image is going to be exploded on a
screen the size of a four-story building
they will even without intending it edit
themselves and i didn't want that i
wanted
alan shepard the inside of alan shepard
to be
my creation mr glenn you are way out of
line
each man here has volunteered to do a
job and doing many things above and
beyond the strict call of duty such as
bringing girls up to your room in the
middle of the night
and foregoing any semblance of an
orderly family life and mr glenn
as long as a man uses good sense what he
does with his zipper or his wick is his
own business
my favorite review i've ever gotten in
my whole
life was after we finished the film then
admiral shepard
wrote a note to phil kaufman and he said
please show this to
scott glenn he said mr glenn
you got me almost perfect
i have no criticism you only missed one
thing
and that is you ain't anywhere near
as good looking as i am
jonathan demi was a good friend of ours
he called me up
and he asked me to come to new york
there's this part
and i want you to play it in silence of
the lambs i'm going to send you to
washington so i went and i spent a
period of time
sitting in on cases case studies still
had bad dreams about some of the stuff i
was exposed to and i haven't led a very
sheltered or
easy life so the stuff i was privy to
the human condition had a degree of
darkness i never knew
existed so it was rough in that way and
you tell him nothing personal starling
believe me you don't want hannibal
lecter inside your head
just do your job but never forget what
he is when we did the table read the
description of
me and jody when we meet it said the
relationship between these two people is
strange are they father and daughter
mentor and student boyfriend and
girlfriend
jonathan at the time as we were reading
he said forget all that guys you can't
play that
there's no way you can play that
complicated a relationship
okay cut to two or three weeks into
shooting the film
there's a scene when jody is coming out
of her office
getting on the limo to go to west
virginia she had a hard time getting in
the limo i opened the back door and i
took her
arm to help her into the into the limo
and jonathan yells cut cut cut
he comes running up to us so he says
scott please don't i don't want you to
touch jody jody said yeah he was just
being polite and jonathan said remember
when we did the table reading and i
told you guys there's no way in the
world you can play that relationship
guess what i've been looking at dailies
and that relationship
is exactly there already and
scott i know if you physically touch her
it's all going to be blown i only want
you to
touch jody twice in this whole movie
when she's gone through the experience
of dealing with this serial killer and
someone has died in her hands i want you
to walk
out of that house and put your arm over
her shoulder and at the very end of the
film
i want you to shake her hand and that
handshake will be so
loaded that's what a great director is
all about
great directing is having that kind of
sensitivity
and being able to make those kind of
calls
carol and i had moved up here to idaho
driving back we stopped off
at paramount to to see jim bridges
who directed me in the first movie i'd
ever done something called baby maker
he looked at me he said oh my god this
is unbelievable i'm doing a movie
that you're perfect for the bad guy
stick around town for three days
meet the producers meet the star who has
cast approval
and i think it will make this happen and
i
said no came up here two weeks later the
phone rings and it's jim bridges again
and he's he said okay now i'm on
location in houston
paramount doesn't want you to do this
part they don't know who you are
come down to houston and we can make
this thing happen
i hop on my my pickup on my way to
houston
i stop outside of huntsville prison
because i know the character i'm playing
and as i'm parked there these two guys
who i know
from another time in my life who were
friends of
freddy fenders
and these guys are arrows
the real thing and one of them walks up
to me
in my truck and he said hey what are you
doing here
are you doing a movie what are you
playing i said bank robber and they go
hey our buddy he's a gringo
bank robber he's getting out today you
want to meet him
i mean my god what a gift so i hung out
with these guys for about a day
and then i i got rid of them because i
wanted to go
try to get a movie not wind up in jail
drove down to houston
irving as off who wanted me to do the
part
deborah winger who wanted me to do the
part
jim bridges who wanted me to do the part
and john for voter god bless him he also
wanted me to do the part so kind of
over paramount's objections they said
yes
and i started one of the three parts of
my life that really played me
mexicans say you eat the worm you're
going to see visions
visions of what i don't know
i ain't a whole mess of my next single
vision yet i sure feel good
you know i i talk about being lucky so i
got on a bull in the huntsville prison
rodeo i was just going to sit
on the ball and then they were going to
cut and stunt rider was going to
actually get on the bull
riding the long shot i'm sitting on this
bull and i don't know where the camera
is i think
you know how close are they so when i
take a rap
uh i take what's illegal in prc but
all the cons do at the huntsville prison
rodeo which is called a suicide wrap
instead of just wrapping the rig around
your hand once
you put lighter fluid and rosin on your
glove
and then you thread it between your
little finger and your ring finger
you take the leather glove
pound it down now you're locked in the
bad part about that
is if both throws you and you have a
suicide rap you're
what they call hung up you're with a
bull wherever it goes and
probably will kill you or jerk your arm
literally out of your body or who knows
but i thought god forbid
some ex-con sees this movie and sees i
didn't take a suicide rap
because my biggest critics are always
the people that actually do the job
so anyway i took the suicide wrap none
of us had figured that the bulls are
used to being in the let out gate
a matter of seconds before they go this
was like 15 minutes while they were
lighting the shot
and finally the bull on camera decided
i'm leaving whether the gate is open or
not and just
jerked up out of the gate if i hadn't
had a suicide rat
i would have slid down behind its butt
and probably been kicked to death
everything literally went into slow
motion i mean i had all the time in the
world and i
looked up i grabbed the tail
i popped it loose we went down the ball
went
forward i hit the ground with a chip
collarbone and a concussion
i don't really remember this but what i
actually did
was jump right back on my feet climb
back on the lead update
jump back on the bull and i saw blood
all around
the wood of the gate and i said is that
my blood is that my blood and it wasn't
it was like one of the stockhandlers
had reached in to grab me to try to save
my life and bit hit
with the bull's horn and shattered his
cheek and it was his blood all over the
place
and i said is that my blood and they
said no scott it's not your blast and
you don't understand if it is you've got
to get hair and makeup here because it's
got to match the shot it's got to match
the shot
i don't i don't remember any of that
the leftovers was the single best acting
experience i've ever had in my life
do a no small part to damon lindelof
three times in my life i've had parts
that played me
and my job was just to get out of the
way
one was urban cowboy one was a play i
did off-broadway called killer joe
and the third was the leftovers where
the writing was
so deep inside me uh when i woke up in
the morning i just say to myself scott
your job today is just stay out of the
way
the other great blessings i had aside
from damon
mimi later as a director and justin
thoreau
as the star and i love those three
people
without them there would have been no
performance from me
if you're asking me when i started
losing my [ __ ]
contrary to the professional opinion of
others i maintain
my [ __ ] remains intact i remember with
the longest
monologue damon told me it's the longest
speech i've ever written in my life i
said what is a couple pages
he said no actually it's seven pages
when it came time to do that scene
and we were in the outback in australia
mimi was going to do it in
cuts and i said you know i think i know
this whole thing can we just
do the whole thing she said sure we'll
do it once
and see what you miss so we went through
the whole i didn't miss any of it
i used to hear voices they started about
five minutes after it happened after
people disappeared
so they put me in an institution we went
through the whole thing and mimi said
oh that was that was great scott
remember when you pick up the tape
recorder and you almost started crying
when you were
listening to your son talk and i said
no she said what do you mean i said i
i don't remember picking up the tape
recorder she said what do you remember
from the scene
i said not much i remember you saying
action
and saying cut so you weren't directing
yourself at all and i'm like
she said would you be willing on the
second take
so that a little bit of you can hang off
and watch it so that
because if you can't direct yourself i
can't direct you either i can't say
at this point could you would you be
willing to do that and i said no
i said actors live their whole life not
just actors
artists for these moments when it does
you
and i'm not willing to do that she said
what do you suggest we do and i said
just a lot of takes
she said it'll wear you out and i said
no so we did i don't know
six seven takes something like that mimi
rather than trying to take control one
way
just let me go until she saw what she
wanted and the whole
experience of doing that show was that
way
i believe the rains will come
and with them a great flood
i have to sing to make it stop it did me
in such a profound way i still
i i miss it a lot miss all those people
wish the show was still on the air
roughly it's a disaster film and the
disaster
is a comet is headed for the earth first
they think it's going to be a near miss
and then the the people that track those
things
figured oh whoops no it's going to hit
it's going to be
the kind of event that killed the
dinosaurs so the defense department
decides to grab
a group of i don't know 50 people bring
these people
into these bunkers in greenland to
restart
civilization all over again and it's
essentially a family
that are in some kind of crisis with
themselves
so we track their their journey trying
to get to greenland
i play someone who is a widower who
deeply misses his wife to the extent
where he's not really concerned with
living or dying
but very much loves this family that's
coming by
my mary went to heaven in this place
and when the good lord's ready for me to
join her i'm going to be right here
in this place too
bags packed and that's what excites me
now about this film and also that a a
little shout out
to uh rick wahl the the director
who did a phenomenal job of directing
this film
and directing me in the film a little
shout out to him
thank you all for once again
watching me and these characters that
i've played
that are iconic really a lot more
because of you
than because of me